BUT FIRST, THE FAIRY TALE PARTY.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
NOW WHEN YOU ARE A KID AND YOUR
MOM OR YOUR DAD READS A BEDTIME
STORY, IT CAN ALL SEEM SO REAL,
RIGHT?
YOU IMAGINE A GIANT BEANSTALK
REACHING UP TO THE SKY AND
LITTLE JACK IS CLIMBING IT.
YOU MAY HAVE BEEN SCARED THAT
THE WOLF WAS GOING TO HUFF AND
PUFF AND BLOW YOUR HOUSE DOWN.
I PERSONALLY ALWAYS LOOKED UNDER
FOOT BRIDGES FOR THE TRIAL AND
THE THREE BILLY GOATS GRUFF.
BUT EVENTUALLY WE GROW UP AND
LEAVE THE FAIRY TALES BEHIND BUT
NOT SO WITH THE NEVER TRUMPERS.
THEY ARE STILL CLINGING TO THEIR
FANTASY, TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
THAT NEVER EXISTS.
PRO-MILITARY OUTLOOK.
NOW YOU MAY NOT KNOW THESE
PEOPLE, THEY HAVE ZERO
CONSTITUENCY.
REPUBLICANS HATE THEM AND
DEMOCRATS ARE JUST USING THEM.
LET ME INTRODUCE THIS TO YOU.
THE FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE PARTY
IS FAILED MAGAZINE EDITOR BILL
KRISTOL WHO FAMOUSLY PREDICTED
THIS IN 2003.
>> WHATEVER YOU CAN SAY ABOUT
THIS WAR, -- >> IT MAY BE.
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> PARKHILL.
>> HE SCOFFED AT THE NOTION OF
DONALD TRUMP WINNING THE
PRESIDENCY, THE NOMINATION IN
2015.
>> THIS TRUMP THING IS GOING ON
I GATHER AND HE'S DOING OKAY IN
THE POLLS FOR A WHILE BUT HE'S
NOT GOING TO BE A NOMINEE EITHE
EITHER.
>> Laura: AND NOW HE CLAIMS TO
BE A TRUMP MIND READER.
>> I THINK HE SEES BAD ECONOMIC
NEWS COMING IN BAD POLITICAL
NEWS COMING AND HE'S A
DEMORALIZED GUY.
>> Laura: HEY BILL, 19 YOUR
HIGH FOR CONSUMER CONFIDENCE,
YOU MIGHT WANT TO REVISE YOUR
REMARKS.
IN CASE YOU FORGOT THIS IS A GUY
WHO THOUGHT A NATIONAL REVIEW
COLUMNIST COULD BE DONALD TRUMP
IN THE SPRING OF 2016.
HE WILL DO IT ALL AT THE
CONVENTION, IT'S GOING TO BE A
BIG DEAL.
AND THIS WAS TOO MUCH FOR TAMIKA
BREZINSKI TO TAKE.
>> >> HE KEPT PLAYING AND THIS
POLITICAL LAND OF MAKE-BELIEVE.
AND THEN, THERE IS KRISTOL'S
BUDDY, BRETT STEVENS.
HE REGULARLY DISHES OUT THE
NASTIEST BILE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS SUPPORTERS.
>> WHAT WE SAW OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS IS A PRESIDENT WHO IS
EITHER MENTALLY UNWELL OR
MORALLY UNSET.
OR MAYBE BOTH.
HE'S LIKE A FRENZY BALLOON, HE
POPPED THE SECOND HE GETS A
LITTLE PINPRICK ON TWITTER.
>> YESTERDAY A PROFESSOR OF
GEORGE WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY
DESCRIBED TO ME AS A
METAPHORICAL BEDBUG.
SO I WROTE HIM A PERSONAL EMAIL.
I ALSO COPIED HIS PROVOST ON THE
NOTE.
PEOPLE ARE UPSET ABOUT THIS AND
I WANT TO BE CLEAR, AND NO WAY
IN WHICH THOSE PEOPLE OR
PROFESSORS OR JOURNALIST
INTERACT WITH THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
>> Laura: WHO DIED AND MADE
HIM HEAD OF HUMAN RESOURCES?
WHAT A GOOFBALL.
AND HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF THIS
WOMAN?
HER NAME IS JENNIFER RUBIN AND
SHE'S DESCRIBED AS A BLOGGER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
EVERY SYLLABLE OUT OF HER MOUTH
WAS THIS CONTEMPT TOWARD
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ANY OF YOU
WATCHING.
THIS MEAGER ACCOMPLISHMENT WANTS
US ALL TO BE BANISHED FROM
PUBLIC LIFE.
>> WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING IS
SHUNNING AND SHAMING THESE
PEOPLE WHICH IS A STATEMENT OF
MORAL INDIGNATION THAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE NOT FIT FOR POLITE
SOCIETY.
WE HAVE TO COLLECTIVELY IN
ESSENCE BURNED ON THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
WE HAVE TO LEVEL THEM.
BECAUSE THERE ARE SURVIVORS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WEATHER
THE STORM AND THEY WILL DO IT
AGAIN.
>> Laura: HER TALK OF BRINGING
IT DOWN AND URGING THAT
POTENTIAL SURVIVORS BE
ELIMINATED, AND TRUMPS RHETORIC?
THAT INCITES VIOLENCE AND IT'S
SHAMEFUL.
BUT ONE OF MY FAVORITE
CHARACTERS IN THE NEVER TRUMPER
NONFICTION SERIES IS THIS FELLOW
NAMED MAX BOOT.
HE BEARS AN UNCANNY RESEMBLANCE
TO MAX HEADROOM.
WHICH ONE IS CUTER?
NOW BEFORE TRUMP GOT ELECTED, HE
SEEMED LIKE A GOOFY MEAL,
HUCKSTER WHOSE COMEDY WAS STUCK
IN 2004.
BUT BOOT CLAIMS THE G.O.P. HAS
SUFFERED A COMPLETE MORAL AND
INTELLECTUAL COLLAPSE.
BY SMEARING EVERYONE WHOSE SKIN
HAPPENS TO BE WHITE, WHO VOTED
FOR TRUMP, WHO CALLS THEM A
BUNCH OF WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
THIS SORRY BUT KIND OF HILARIOUS
LOT DOESN'T UNDERSTAND, AT THEIR
FAIRY TALE HOUSE IT'S ALREADY
BURNED DOWN.
IN 2008 AND IN 2012 WHEN THEY
LOST THE PRESIDENCY TWICE TO
OBAMA.
THEN TRUMP COMES IN AND BUILDS A
NEW PARTY THAT DREW IN PEOPLE
FROM THE OBAMA CAMP AND VOTED
FOR HIM THE FIRST TIME.
PEOPLE HADN'T VOTED FOR HIM FOR
A WHILE.
THEY RECOGNIZE THAT OBAMA AND
THE END WOULD CASH OUT ONCE HE
LEFT OFFICE, THE LITTLE PEOPLE
BE.
BUT THE NEVER TRUMPER FANTASY, I
WAS THINKING ABOUT IT TODAY,